the ceo of pfizer
uh has said um that it is likely that
people are gonna need a third
shot a booster shot of the pfizer
covet vaccine a year after getting the
first two
and they're um that there may just need
to be an annual
um an annual routine of shots and
apparently the j
j guy i don't know if it was the ceo or
not um said something similar
as well with regard to their shot um so
you know of course this raises the
question like maybe maybe this is just
going to be like the flu shot
um where the virus is evolving out from
under us as we know it to be
and so boosters are required to get a
closer fit to the actual virus the
people who are developing the vaccine
can get a closer fit to the actual virus
that is maximally in circulation at the
time
but you know it does raise the question
for me it
raises so many questions but do any of
the vaccine manufacturers actually have
a good idea of like what a closer fit to
any of the current variants would be
or do we have any way of knowing what
variants are actually going to be
maximally circulating
uh let's separate two things traditional
booster shots are necessary not because
of the change of the virus but because
of the degradation
of the immunological memory you're right
i used booster
i used booster incorrectly although the
pfizer ceo did as well
that does not yeah breed confidence yeah
i was i was i was using his language but
you're right anyway
i don't want to nitpick i just want to
say there are two reasons you know so
the flu shot that you supposedly should
get every year is about the fact that
it's a different
it's a new vaccine yes because it's a
new flu
right and that seems like so that's what
may be happening here with kova well
both things are likely to happen here
with covet okay
so on the one hand we have the very
frightening prospect
that the way that these vaccines target
the spike protein is going to cause
these
escape mutants to dominate and that we
will be chasing
we're basically just signed up for an
arms race and that we are
learning of um the nature of that arms
race that this is you know
i don't know so why aren't both things
always happening though i mean
again we're going to go back to virus
origins and you know maybe this is
evolving so rapidly
in such a unpredictable way precisely
because uh
it did not it is not like any other
virus we've seen before
but you know why doesn't say um needing
to get a rabies booster every 10 years
if your titers are low for instance
um not about both um
in you know increasing your titers and
also
um with new variants of rabies that has
evolved in those ten years
um in the rabies case it's easy i think
because rabies is so very rare
that what you have is a virus that
doesn't have a large canvas on which to
paint and for which there is not
a lot of pressure for it to evolve since
such a tiny percentage of any population
has rabies the point is rabies
traditional rabies always has naive
animals um to infect so it doesn't get
an advantage for change
so potentially the more common the
pathogen the more difficult
um it will be to make a vaccine that is
targeted and targeted for a while
and you know maybe even i actually have
no idea but you know i've been tracking
for decades like
hoping for the malaria vaccine like
really really hoping for it and yeah
it turned you know maybe an mrna vaccine
um
and i don't know um but uh
somehow that one is super elusive in a
way that other mosquito vector diseases
um like yellow fever have not been yep
um so
i think two things are true one um there
is
a large landscape of immunological
understanding
and then there's a large landscape of
what we don't know i mean
i will not cite donald rumsfeld in this
case but uh
his wisdom is relevant here with respect
to what we do and don't know
it turns out there is some far more
ancient philosophical
uh thing that he was actually riffing on
when he talked about the known knowns
and the known unknowns and the unknown
knowns and the unknown unknowns
well the thing is i'm a little addicted
to the cringe when you
um when you invoke donald rumsfeld as a
a source of wisdom you know he's like
the
the evil yogi berra or something like
that but
but in any case um so we may or may not
be dealing with
both a booster situation here yeah where
your
your immunological memory decays over
time and therefore you need a booster to
remind your immune system hey this thing
is still out there yeah
and we are almost certainly dealing with
this
um case where we are putting intense
pressure
on the uh the spike protein
by targeting it very narrowly with a
vaccine that focuses
only on that and indeed only on the
original variant of the spike protein
which basically means that any way in
which the spike protein can
change that is electromagnetically
dissimilar from the original spike
protein
gives it an advantage in hiding from the
immune system and so
voila there's your arms race yeah yep
there's your arms race
people who have been fully vaccinated
can still spread the virus question mark
true
are there other examples of this outside
of kovid it seems like more scare
tactics
so this is something just got stated
today right was it fouchy
who i don't know someone just said this
well this
is apparently true um as far as i know
it's not um all that rare
because vaccines are essentially never
perfectly successful in preventing
disease
okay but but yeah it seems to me that
you just conflated two things
if you are vaccinated and you can't get
it
can you spread it no so then so so you
you
what you said it seems like it conflates
these two things and what fouchy or the
who whoever is saying this thing they're
not being clear
well the evidence is clear
right so well i i hope that's true like
every time i've tried to go down this
particular rabbit hole i can't
distinguish between these two
possibilities
because they're not they're not sharing
it so like if they are claiming
that somehow this this magic virus and
this magic vaccine
are combining in such a way that if
you're vaccinated you can't get the
thing but you can still spread it
like i don't know what planet we live on
and i really want to see what those data
look like but
that's not that's not what anybody's
saying okay you can get it
if you had the vaccine you can get it
and you're much more likely to be
asymptomatic because one thing that the
vaccine seems very good at is reducing
the severity of disease
which also reduces the degree to which
you are likely to transmit it
because right of course your symptoms
are a matter of the virus producing
on the other hand being vaccinated
you're less likely to be taking the same
kinds of precautionary measures
um to avoid spreading um and you are
going to think that you're immune to it
because you were vaccinated
and you know we did a whole takedown of
that crap paper on asymptomatic spread
being really really common
yeah but we still don't know like we
just took down that paper we don't know
to what degree a symptomatic spread
actually can happen it's clearly less
than symptomatic spread
but beyond that we don't know and so if
you've got vaccinated people
who assume that they are now immune
whose a
small proportion of them are not but are
behaving as if they are
they will be if they do get it they will
be more likely to spread it than if they
had not been vaccinated
actually because they presumably would
have been behaving differently yes and
the frightening possibility here
is if you have been vaccinated
you have been vaccinated against the
original version of the spike protein
which means what are you likely to get
what is likely to get around
the immune system's uh vaccinated state
is a variant therefore if you spread it
what are you likely to spread
some variant from the vaccine it's
selective pressure
for a vaccine avoidant virus exactly yes
again welcome to the arms race right
cool what is your current thinking on
relative vaccine safety
heather i believe you said that you
would prefer a viral vector vaccine for
yourself
thoughts on the recent blood clot
stories um
there's a lot of questions in there um
we already talked a little bit about the
blood clot
stuff you know that i think it's again
it's like
i hope that the blood clot stories are
like the seat belts in the car
the vaccine is still affording greater
safety than
um than than damage i think
pulling j j or proposing that people
should be cautious about j and j
for six bad cases in over six million
is an insane thing to have done that's
that those numbers make
no sense um i
still wish that we had many more years
behind us of these vaccines before we
were being expected to take them
we will be eligible to get vaccinated
soon here in oregon
and i would i hope j
j remains available and um
that we can wait as long as possible
yeah i would say
the number of ways in which this is
unsafe are many
and it is clear and we are not having a
proper public discussion about it jim
and i are having a proper discussion
but i don't hear it elsewhere there's
the personal safety dimension
there's the safety of this vaccination
campaign
um there is the danger of the way
markets are interfacing
with the various vaccines on offer
you know is there a perverse incentive
driving the claim that we may need
a third booster
is there a perverse incentive that
results in proclamations about the
danger of one vaccine versus another
is there a perverse incentive preventing
us from discussing
uh both the long-term risks of these
vaccines
and the risk of affecting the pandemic
in a way that will make things worse and
not better
all of these things are absent from the
discussion um
and they exist only discussed on the
fringe and that's
absurd and in light of all of this
the idea that we are going to be forced
with vaccine
passports to accept vaccinations that
have not been
about which no one has been honest about
the hazards is
extremely distressing it's diabolical
it's diabolical and i would say you know
what
in a good regime in a regime in which we
did proper due diligence about vaccine
safety
in which there were no perverse
incentives surrounding
the mythology about which ones are safe
and how safe they are and all of that
i would be in favor of vaccine passports
but
i am not at all in favor of them in the
context
of a system that will not discuss
rationally what the actual hazards might
be
i don't think they're safe enough
you